bonjour bienvenue sur tiago nal tv
spéciale le son avec jean baptiste
blondeau jean bâtiments dont stéphane
dans tout le monde alors on va voir
aujourd'hui une arme anti sicilienne à
connaître absolument qui s'appelle non
tout à fait course automobile puisque sa
frappe l attaque grand prix oui bizarre
je sais même pas l'origine d'une 11 le
nom se dit en français est un grand prix
y ait l'idée aussi en anglais grand prix
à taiwan depuis attaque
pourquoi ce serait intéressant
d'ailleurs cherché j'ai pas vraiment
trouvé l'origine en tous les cas c'est
une anti sicilienne comme tu l'as dit
anti syrienne c'est toutes les variantes
avec les blancs ou les blancs d'oeufs
n'ouvre pas la cia ne joue pas qu'à
liège 3 et des quatre mois l'a de suite
voilà donc c'est une sorte de sicilienne
fermé mais mais à moitié faire face est
un troll et de cuincy l'attaquent deux
flancs en fait
tac de côté donc c'est une sorte de
sienne fermer quand même avec un
développement rapide du fou en c4 et une
attaque rapide sur la colonne f1 petit
peut être vite pénible si on n'est pas
bien préparé sa savent c'est
effectivement c'est très embêtant et
ça va vraiment très vite en fait il faut
il faut bien avoir les idées clés en
tête pour pouvoir jouer contre cette
attaque grand prix donc à conseiller
pour les blancs pourquoi pas pour
surprendre un adepte de la sicilienne
contre eux qui vous pourriez avoir des
problèmes et bien ça peut être une arme
tout à fait tout à fait intéressante
alors on va voir ça tout de suite
donc ça démarre par une sicilienne c5 et
la cave les c3 déjà donc ça veut dire
déjà en donne la couleur on va pas
ouvrir avec des quatre puisqu'on n'a pas
joué mais pas tout de suite on dit pas
tout de suite mais pas tout de suite
c'est toujours un peu fourbe d'ailleurs
parce que on peut parfois retardé le
coups des quatre dates mais normalement
ceux ci n fermer les les noirs sont
suffisamment bien pour que le coût des
quatre qui n'a pas été préparée de suite
ne soit jamais jouable c'est d'ailleurs
l'explication du deuxième coup des noirs
calais cci c'est celle ci renforce le
contrôle de descartes et souvent on va
jouer avec g6 fou g7 pour rajouter
encore un contrôle exactement c'est la
base 6ème fermé pour les noirs voilà
alors la sicile une ferme et les blancs
rouges et 3 way hélas hélas tu as grand
prix c'est un peu différent on joue f4
tout de suite alors f qui a tout de
suite parce qu'en fait on veut profiter
du fait on sait que les noirs vont
vouloir jouer j'ai six fours g7
oui et on veut profiter de ça pour jouer
une rupture rapide par f5
voilà on va voir à la disposition donc
g6 toute façon et le coup logique quand
même cavalier f3 fou j'ai sept g7
logique aussi fous ces quatre pouces et
4 alors assailli a lancé un peu dit donc
c'est là qu'on voit là ça diffère c'est
entre la fermer et puis les autres donc
on met le fou sur cette diagonale parce
qu en conjonction avec le coup f4 f5 ici
si les noirs jouent par exemple s'ils
sont en fait on va voir c'est que ça va
on va essayer d'affaiblir 7,7 diagonale
en fait ouais tout va se jouer là dessus
bon en fait l'idée qui va être le fil
rouge de cette leçon stéphane c'est en
fait le fou c4 d'une pièce très forte et
une pièce que les blancs veulent faire
vivre à tout prix parce que c'est une
pièce dangereuse pour attaque sur le roi
est la clé pour les noirs c'est on va
survivre à l'attaqué grand prix si
jamais on arrive à gérer correctement la
puissance du fou ces quatre voilà si ce
fou c4 est une pièce très forte dans ces
cas-là on perdra et si on arrive à le
museler ces cas là les noirs auront un
avantage alors on va voir le déjà par
exemple ce qu'il faut pas faire ouais
alors par exemple le coût des six auprès
des 600 déjà rien
discutable bon déjà revenons un peu en
arrière
peut-être voilà c'est une question de
logique c'est quel est le coût de pion
parmi les deux parmi les deux coups de
pions centraux quelques points qui est
le plus logique
bon d'abord on rejette le coup de
cavaliers enlève 6 puisque lecavalier
n'est pas stabilisée au centre à cause
du coût du coup et 500 tout de suite
donc ça va pas du tout donc il faut
jouer un pion pour stabiliser la sortie
du cavalier alors on remet le cavalier
voilà alors est-ce qu'on sort plutôt un
f6 auquel cas il faut jouer des six où
elle ce qu'on le sort plutôt en deux
sets où quelqu'un il faut jouer eux 6
alors l'idée de fusion 6 on joue déjà
contrôle poussé quatre voilà ces soucis
aussi simple que ça en fait on veut
museler ce fou c4 donc on préfère jouer
e6 et le coup cavalier e set
nous nous intéresse non seulement non
seulement parce qu'ils contrôlent la
case f5 donc éventuellement la poussée
des blancs sur f5
mais aussi ils préparent la poussée du
pion 17 en d5 est donc là on va
carrément enterré le fou voilà donc
c'est précis donc que six est clairement
le meilleur coût regardons d'abord le
coup de dés 6 on va voir le coût des six
qui est notre idéal aurait évidemment
sion jeu des c's c'est parce qu'on
voudrait sortir le cavalier plutôt un f6
et on va justement c'est ça donne tout
venait de cette attaque
on va voir les petits roms tout simple
petit rock maintenant on joue quand même
six oui parce que on veut quand même
évité de d'avoir à subir ça qu'on va
affaiblir drôlement les dans ces cas là
on se rend compte que effectivement si
on veut jouer deux des cinq plus tard le
coût des systèmes servi à rien et oui
c'est ça on a perdu un temps voilà donc
par rapport à ça donc là tout de suite
fcm la faille c'est l'heure déjà alors
ça c'est un gros souci alors évidemment
si les noirs prennent tout de suite au
fcm par exemple eux prend 1,5 et ça
donne tout le potentiel du fou c4
d'ailleurs si tu me permets je voudrais
revenir à cette notion après deux coups
au cices larron on a dit que l'idée
c'était de d5 et donc on aurait perdu un
temps si on veut jouer des cinq noms
mais je dire après cavaliers ou 7,6 ont
besoin de dessin ça veut dire qu'on
aurait joué le pion des en deux temps
oui donc des six des 5
maintenant si tu veux bien on va au
deuxième coup blanc cavaliers c3
imaginons maintenant quand on joue
contre un joueur qui joue la nage dorff
voilà qui joue la neige doit offrir ou
des six donc s'il joue là système fermé
qui joue cavalier ses 6 au deuxième coup
donc déjà il jouera pas de nash dorff
d'accord donc s il veut maintenir son
système grenache d'offres ils jouent des
six mais on sait que des si ce n'est pas
le meilleur système contre l'attack
grand prix n'est sûr d'accord donc
justement on va donc il faut jouer
cavalier c6 donc on y va au deuxième
coup car il sait si c'est le meilleur
contre attaque grand prix hélas il est
blond joue cavalier f399 voilà ils
veulent ouvrir la sicilienne est bien le
joueur du nahd j'avais sorti son système
noces d'or là on rentre dans les
méandres de l'ordre de coûts qui s'y
intéressant dans les ouvertures et
d'ailleurs au haut niveau on trouve des
très fort joueur type à nantes par
exemple qui ont joué à l'attack grand
prix quasiment systématiquement contre
des joueurs par exemple comme boris
gelfand qu'un adepte inconditionnel de
la nasa offre parce que le coût des six
lui pose un problème au deuxième coup
c'est pas rare de voir un joueur a
hésité longtemps au deuxième coup parce
qu'il est sorti voilà donc c'était une
petite parenthèse mais qui mérite d'être
précisée parce que nous quand on
travaille les ouvertures et bien il ya
ceux il ya cette partie des ordres de
coûts qui est réservé bon à des fins à
des connaisseurs mais voilà qu'elle
toute cette finesse un très fin très fin
donc on comprend l'idée alors heureux
ces cas difficiles à déceler si c'est
pas bon cela exemple en exemple si rock
aussi une partie de team and beauty
mannequin d'ailleurs un excellent en
théorie si la wii est connu pour être
très très très très bon théoricien petit
grand roque petit rock aussi c'est
maintenant quand même alors pourquoi pas
directement cavaliers 6 on peut se poser
la question alors qu'à 26 le problème
c'est que on a stabilisé provisoirement
peut-être le cavalier parce que la voix
poussé aux cinq n'est pas n'est pas
possible mais de toute façon on venait
on va peut-être quand même se prendre 5
1 j'aime bien le coup de main aussi
demain même coup de main parce qu'il
sait ni des multiples d'abord poussé e5
est éventuellement est aussi amené la
dame en h4 qui est une une qui unit des
principales de la tacc grand prix fille
aux 5 ou 6 e 5 e 6 soit le 5e voilà
aussi en lisant les karellis g5y presque
matlama
ouais voilà qu'on amène le cavalier là
on échange voilà c'est ça ça va très
vite donc il faut faire des pieds alors
l'option jouage 6 évidemment ça après
détroit le fouillis
il va rêver de matériel donc voilà les
idées alors des six petits rock e66
quand même donc au moment où mon père en
tendance effectivement quand tu disais
une arme une arme peut être anti joueurs
de l'âge d'or voilà donc ça ça
m'intéresse parce que j'en connais un
mois qu'ils me la joue à chaque fois et
qui qui pourrait être embêté c'est bien
si tu veux jouer devant tous vers façon
rien ne t'empêche de jouer cavalier c3
d'abord oui on travaille f3 ensuite et
là je fais peut-être l'embêter tout à
fait réfléchir f5 f5
quand même donc tout de suite ouais
alors on pourrait ne pas jouer à 100 ou
de suite
ouais mais c'est quand même un coup
hyper intéressant parce qu'on ouvre les
lignes sur le roi 8 encore problème
c'est que si les noirs on laisse les
noirs prendre jouer cavalier carillo set
ça sera plus jamais possible
le problème quand les blancs jouent f5
ne faut pas que les noirs puis jouer des
voilà voilà et là ils peuvent pas jouer
dès 5 ans quoi donc donc il faut jouer
maintenant il faut il faut y aller tout
de suite que prochaine à tous c'est trop
tard
on a 400 f 5 voit la menace pas m6
puisque le carif trois bouches la tour
très important et à ce moment là des 5
voilà donc faut être très précis f5
maintenant alors que prend f5 donc là
maintenant alors est ce qu'on peut faire
faut voir les deux prises oui alors on
va voir d'abord j'ai pris cinq peut-être
un léger problème 5 voilà on prend tout
simplement on prend et le milieu avant
ça serait quand même assez assez moche
entre guillemets de reprendre du pillon
parce que la structure c'est horrible et
affaibli on donne la case des 5 et puis
le roi noir n'a pas ça d'abris imminent
donc je vais déjà faire un petit échec
éventuellement le ont aussi joué tout
simplement des trois menaces cavalli j5
des trous tout est bon là je dirais que
les blancs sont bien ont obtenu un
avantage de positionnelle clair clair f5
donc que prend 8,5 alors évident si on
fait pas prendre si on joue
par exemple cavaliers au 7 mai on va
voir les autres possibilités encore un
nom pompeux on peut prendre peut prendre
un v6 et sur une prise sur une prise par
alors là c'est là c'est ce qu'on sera
pas les parce que sur fou prend pions
prend il ya un coup comme cai g5 arly g5
alors attaque aussi ce empêche le rock
ouais on faudrait jouer dame 17
mais là on a on a tôt ou tard tirer une
pénétration en accepte alors on pourrait
tôt ou tard menacé de mettre une tour en
f7 sur le coloriage 630 sans compter le
coût des quatre le ku'damm gk tout
simplement qu'ils qui est très bon mais
nancy et lorient notre coupe aussi mais
aussi six cavaliers b5
à oui avec des idées effectivement de
cavaliers prend 1,6 on peut jouer qu'à
les regarder par exemple imaginer que
les noirs jouent à 6 voilà déjà on peut
pas faire grand roque
regardez on peut pas faire partir à
cause de la tour si grand roque
cavalière s'est shut up fourchette entre
les deux tours il y aura une fourchette
et si les noirs jouent à 6 regardez ces
superbes kavli propre fils c'est
horrible presse que le cas le fou g7 et
emprises et aux menaces en même temps
qu'avait laissé cet échec
et s'il n'en prend ainsi une triple
fourchette pouf et la dame ait perdu non
seulement la tour est en reprise mais
surtout la dame ouais donc aller bessin
qui était une
est un beau piège et là faudrait jouer
un coup comme cavalier des huit qui fait
pas beau qui est pas beau à voir mais on
peut pas encore ok donc c'est un peu ce
petit peu en béton ramallah se craquelle
et b5 intéressant on pourrait aussi que
les carrières à trois pendant pour venir
ans et 4 rebonds et d'affaiblir à tous
ceux et puis on peut pas invoquer le cas
et 18 en plus empêche le rock
donc je vais pas me 2 tout simplement
protection de cavaliers et sur a6
envisagé de revenir même en a trois pour
coincer dans ces cas après ces trois cas
valls et de aussi où ces trois des
quatre aides est possible d'en acheter
alors f5 donc il faut prendre le
problème 5.5 détroit voilà on ne reprend
pas en fait
voilà maintenant on a obtenu avec les
blancs en fait l'ouverture de la grande
diagonale pour notre fou donc maintenant
des superbes se frottent on continue le
développement il fait peur un matin il
s'agit pas d'attaquer quand même trop
tôt et si cinor freine fort mal avec kmg
sein alors la cave les g5 tout le mérite
et là tu attaques directes sur le pion à
vii on a une seule défense et l'euro
donc ça va pas du tout préparés parce
que sur f6 au bien quand même 4e set
avec la fameuse fourchette classique
dont la tant que ça marche pas donc
c'est pas bon on regarde et on peut donc
il faut non c'est pour quand même pour
montrer les pièges façon l'oncle ici
cavalière 6 par exemple on pourra jouer
cavalier c est aussi l attaque normal
avec demain ce sera de savoir et à main
c'est pareil ça va ressembler la sortie
c'est la même idée alors que les six
dames 1
alors d'amener un classique donc cette
disposition de pièces ses classiques du
grand prix avec d'un match 4 le fou en
chine et cahiers g5 île quasi mat avec
affaiblissement intégral de toutes à
toute la structure autour du roi alors
petit rire quand même parce que sinon le
roi et au centre ça peut vite s'ouvrir
aussi d'un match face à mach 4 quand
même bien sûr la balle allait noir ont
joué cavalier des quatre équipes qui
essayent d'échangés cavaliers lecavalier
f3 créer une pièce d'attac en attaquant
ses deux mais je dirais que c'est 2 c de
la broutille on n'a pas droit à ce qui
va se passer sur les vins
parce que c'est quasi matin alors fou g5
ou g5 quand même qu'est ce qui se passe
ici les noirs me s'ils prennent par
exemple en c2 déjà mais là on va
profiter directement du cloître
convaincre et khaled et 5 et ça y est le
cavalier perdu il ya triple à j-6 triple
h sur la dame et on reprend de cavaillon
dernière à au moins une pièce et il ya
même une attaque de mort et oui je crois
porte pas que le devoir survivre moi
c'est quasi matin donc non ils sont
obligés d'en empêcher le coup voilà la
vallée des saints dans fou aussi il faut
absolument faut empêcher carlier des
cinq donc dans ce cas là maintenant
prendre des cartes on a une bonne à une
telle suite ici avec calle prend des cas
on va ouvrir la regarde on ouvre on
ouvre la tour sur le sol qu'alexis le
faut aussi se peut pas à la fois
défendre f5 et le potentiel voilà les
noirs ont voulu en fait éliminer une
pièce d'attac qui était le cavalier mais
en fait il donne vie à une nouvel
épisode taxer la tour f 1 ouais donc le
bon tu reprends des 4 et regardez-les
ide pro f 5
ça fait mal parce qu'il ya le foot
emprise alors imaginons clé
par exemple les blancs face fou prend
fou par exemple on peut jouer maintenant
le cavalier et ça y est liée à la
triplette ici / f 4k vallée prend c'est
la même fou près en fou prend la dame
est attaquée suivi de damages six essais
matt angers7
oui ça va très vite on peut pas faire ça
donc il faut prendre le cavaly vs vous
prendre ce cavalier qui menacent de qui
menaçait de faire la fameuse triplette
ouais mais là ça va déjà très mal pour
les problèmes voyez que ça va ça va
vraiment vite on prend des pions frd
déjà une triplette ici sur m6 il
faudrait prendre 6 d'ailleurs c'est ce
qua non si on prend on y apprend aussi
ce faux pas même si c'est suivi depuis
on prend ces trois là on a un avantage
imaginons et matériels voilà il ya un
avantage matériel à prix fous prend
aussi soin julien la sphère de foudre
une position ouverte c'est une position
qui est marrant c'est royal perd de fou
à taille l'autre tour va venir c'est
horrible ouais ça fait trop peur clouage
en plus qu'aux jeux qu'on pourrait faire
contre ce cavalier est là en fait les
noirs en pont on pensait qu'ils avaient
le temps de jouer des os 10 5
voilà c'est clair on parle effectivement
on coupe ça y est enfin
on coupe se foulent le problème c'est
que regarder les courbes magnifiques du
joueur hollandais qui est qu'ils jouent
eux 7
alors pourquoi puisqu'il veut éviter que
les noirs ne reprenne le pion à eux avec
le pion f pour libérer à tour même même
les blancs ne veulent pas prendre de
même parce que la tour aurait une action
sur le cavalier f6 cloud et qu'ils
défendraient alors que maintenant ce
cavalier f6 je dirais qu'il est qu'il
est mort c'était la fin de la partie
mais ce câble et voilà c'est l'idée si
on garde ce clou âgées il faut faire
dans province est est ce que l'on va le
laisser tout simplement un jouet un coup
tranquille
ainsi que de la tacc four b3 ou ailleurs
ça c'est énorme puisque le foot qu'on
arrive car il s'y est perdu c'est bien
on peut dire que c'est fini mon sens de
la pièce tout simplement et il est même
l'échec intermédiaire en c5 ne suffit
pas oui puisqu'on a le coup de dés 4
alors c'est prendre b2 est sûre alors
sur dame ces cinq échecs on joue comme
il des cas voilà et engage la pièce
quand même puisque la dame h cartes
protège la case donc on peut parier
chèque est mon problème donc sur ces
prendre les deux tours a eu un effet sur
26,5 des quatre voilà c'est fini et on
fera la pièce puisque m6 est perdu voilà
donc il n'y a pas d'échec intermédiaires
et donc voilà ça va très vite
donc vous voyez pourquoi des si c'est
une faute je crois tout les idées donc
le bon coup finalement c'est le coup
aussi sur la cua aussi ce bon alors là
on joue et contrôler le fou c4 parce
qu'on va vous la jouer des scènes très
vite oui alors là il ya maintenant il ya
deux choses qu'il faut qu'il faut
retenir
enfin il ya un principe c'est à dire que
si on joue mollement avec détroit et
petit rock pour finir le développement
les noirs n'ont aucune raison de
s'inquiéter ils vont jouer cavalier e
set des cinq hommes comme des flèches
indiquent et le fou et musclé et donc
l'ouverture blanche n'a pas trop de sens
soit on continue à aller vite
- jouez f5 alors on regarde 9,5 voilà
c'est ça l'idée ouais c'est l'idée de la
taxe sinon ça va être la même idée de
son regard dont peut-être
le coût des trois qui est en bas de
notre époque où la voilà si on joue ou
alors cavalier e set il paraît que petit
rucks où j'aurai beaucoup un carlos est
très vite et on veut jouer des 5
voilà rapidement les trois faux b3 bon
dessin bien sûr petit rock petit rush
petit road à mehun dames 1 ea cavaliers
à 5 on enfonce le clou on va même
supprimer ce super classe blanche
supprimer fou des deux a été jouée par
les par les blancs voyez que c'est pas
une attaque directe un bon cavalier ses
six essais ce qui est une gaffe parce
que maintenant sur cavaliers d un homme
parce que les blancs pensent et forcer
la décision et recycler les cavaliers
sur sur les droits et bien on a ces
quatre c4
il fouille est perdu alors il ya fou à
4.4 et b5 les baies 5 quand même voilà
parce que sur fou prend il ya il faudra
ya le fameux dame b 6 le fameux alors
cette histoire de prendre le fou comme
ça ça s'appelle l'arche de noé c'est
leur large de dori pas pourquoi
s'appelle comme ça on en a on la mène en
bateau que ça il est emmené honda
d'expression des phrases échec on se
demande pourquoi ces jolies la bête
d'accord voilà donc b5 superbe un procès
ne marche pas à cause de dame b 6 échecs
classique il faut connaître cette cette
technique d'arche de noé
voilà la renommée mais aussi bon pour se
recentrer sur notre ouverture l'idée
cavaliers à 5 pour pour prendre ce four
b3 donc on va en menace ses quatrains de
toute façon c'est la menace
ouais et que font les blancs ça ouais
ouais bof c'est pas vous il va y avoir
quand il ya 3 qui est un peu triste
aussi 3 mai alors évidemment sur a3 on
prend tout simplement on prend puis ont
déstructuré on a rien c'est la structure
n'a une super casse des 4,1 à très
belles cases pour le cavalier on a cassé
la structure
non mais c'est un désastre je suis
d'accord mais parce que les blancs ont
joué trop donc maintenant qu'est ce qui
se passe si les blancs jouent alors faut
voir là la vraie attaque 1
voilà le genre d'idée on joue contre le
fou toujours c'est ça cette idée il faut
supprimer ce fou et créer des faiblesses
en même temps si on peut donc cavalier
g7 l'idée c'est de montrer que ce fou il
me placer finalement quelque sorte
malgré que ce soit un fou date alors la
menace des noirs des cinq menace des
noirs desseins qui ouvre le foot c'est
vite sur le plan f 5 voilà on prendrait
le plan gratos comprendre et à 4 et
ensuite f5
non seulement elle semble même se marie
bien sûr tout serait emprise en fait f
prend aussi ce donc la f3 aussi
s'efforcer alors on peut voir quand même
sur petit rock petit rock parce que là
il y aurait eu près f5
ouais tout simplement sur dame le vin
par exemple
non mais ça serait sûrement jour et
enjouée sur un jour des 5 6 1 voilà sur
petit rock je pense qu'il faut pas
prendre 9 5 parce que là on ouvrirait
l'agglo n'a pas l'obligation mais
surtout jouer des scènes voilà sûr il
faudrait des frites des cinq jeux aussi
bien en b3 par exemple on peut jouer ces
quatre éléments
il est mort ce full auto bi s'échanger
contre le cas ici six oui oui oui voilà
de toute façon donc il va être dans la
mesure du possible et c'est de ne pas
prendre le pion avec le pion f5 avec le
pion peut il faut pas essayer de faux
pas ou alors des pauvres radio n'est
donc donc qu'à l'egypte 7 donc et
francis lopez 3e 6 donc forcé alors si
on fait f prend aussi son retour dans le
même genre de vendre que ça qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure qui n'est pas tellement
défavorables aux blancs qui donne même
de l'initiative a on a vu la valse des
cavaliers tout à leur pénible donc des
prend 1,6 et le bon coup à
l'inconvénient c'est qu'on peut plus
jouer le coup des cinq là pour vous
aider mais là quand même notre duo de
pions f7 six musées y bien le voilà de
nouveau en plusieurs fonds série qui
contrôle bien donc on respecte quand
meme
le principe le pot principe des trois au
rock petit à petit voilà cavaillé t4 et
on commence à éliminer les pièces de la
structure est favorable noir un la case
d'éclater une case que les blancs n'ont
pas en déçu avant postes sur une colonne
suit ouverte - les blancs n'ont pas
l'équivalent parce que même là il n'y a
pas de casse faible si c'est pas
vraiment faible n'ya pas il faudrait
qu'ils aient un pion à cabaye prend des
quatre s'éprend des quatre logique la
ligue 2 et cavalli ses six salles avec
les pieds sont harmonieuses prend place
et on va pouvoir même jouer cavalier à 5
est supprimée sous voilà mais même sur
foulée 2 qui a été joué cavalier à cinq
quand même voilà hélas le fou et les
prix voilà il faudrait donner l'autre
fou mais dans ce cas là on donne la
paire de faux ça va pas beaucoup mieux
s'est pas beaucoup
voilà voilà donc là les noirs ont
égalisé proprement voire même en plus de
perspectives que les blancs ici d'accord
donc ça veut dire que très clairement
sur la taille grand prix font vraiment
il faut supprimer ce fossé 4 tout de
suite ça suffit pour donner davantage
c'est la seule préoccupation ouais voilà
donc aussi ce direct voilà alors après
il ya un jeu en fait pourquoi on montre
cette ouverture est un grand prix parce
que les joueurs avec les noirs soit
sicilienne se font sauter à la gorge et
perdre des partis sans jouer quasiment
oui maintenant accès après cette leçon
on espère que ça sera pas ce ne sera pas
le cas oui bien sûr alors qu'est ce qui
se passe quand les blancs jouent un peu
plus mou faut pas rêver vous n'allez pas
gagner tout le temps avec les noirs si
nous jouons comme à nantes joue ça avec
les blancs c'est que c'est pas perdant
non mais par contre ils jouent quelque
chose de plus lents ils vont chercher à
gagner plus tard mais ils sont contents
déjà de sortir qu'on l'a précisé au
début leurs adversaires de leur système
de nage des enfants malades à ça c'est
les forces voir l'emploi c'est pour
c'est parce que c'est un mélange de
variantes et ça peut faire perdre les
pédales
c'est en fait c'est une arme de
dissuasion quelques soirées un petit peu
voilà c'est une arme de dissuasion par
rapport à un âge d'or c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre c'est un joueur qui va
quand même jouer des six va avoir des
problèmes - the dragon on voit là un
jour d'autres groupes qu'il vous si vous
n'avez pas vous prendre le dragon vous
pouvez essayer par deux coups de
différent moi ce que je fais d'ailleurs
la plupart du temps quand je sais à
l'avant ce que mon adversaire joue une
sixième kim kim qui me plaît pas ou qui
m'inspire pas le jour précis et bien je
le joue cahier c3 ou deuxième coup je
regarde ce qu'il fait et après je
m'adapte et si je vous dis ici jouent
des six je vais probablement pas jouer
il va rentrer ouverte voilà je vais les
jouer but de rendre fermé de type grand
prix type f4 là et si ici me joue
un autre coup comme cali ces six là je
lui propose cavaliers trois cavaliers
aux deux avec l'idée de d4 voilà et
jouer une variante ouverte de cécilienne
qui n'est pas celle qui joue
habituellement pas même s'il joue un
dragon accéléré c est différent du
dragon comme un sur la sueur nation
voilà c'est pas la même les ordres de
coûts aux échecs
bon alors la tacc grand prix très
importantes pour sortir l'adversaire de
ceux nombreux coups donc une subtilité
puis une attaque à connaître puisque on
peut gagner comme vous l'avez vu des
parties et on peut gagner partie très
très rapidement merci jean baptiste a
pris au revoir à bientôt sur canal tv